when you're a browns fan
you're always waiting you're on edge
right the what's lurking around the
corner whether it's a miles garrett
broken ankle playing basketball or just
this idea
that the chiefs have all their guys
there for the offseason workouts the
browns who face kansas city in kansas
city to start the season don't miles
garrett was asked yesterday about
whether he's got any concern regarding
that discrepancy here's what he had to
say in response
not at all
i'm glad they they have attendance but
and just because they're getting getting
work at you know their facility doesn't
mean we're not working just because
we're we're away our needs are getting
work i guess
you know working on their craft just
away from home
we have that freedom and that liberty
and no
no when we get to game one we'll see
who has been gelling better and who's
who's got the upper
hand yeah look uh
easy
this is one of the major
flies in the ointment as it relates to
this push by the union to get guys to
not show up because there will be
competitive disparities and even as we
see some teams reducing the intensity
reducing the number of practices getting
away from different drills the patriots
are still the patriots the chiefs are
still the chiefs
you know and and we don't hear anything
from like like the like we've talked
about some of the other teams too
there's a lot of teams out there they're
kind of like quietly the attendance is
really good and we never heard one thing
about it and they're just chipping away
at work
and and i i
i wonder how much when september rolls
around and we've got
16 games per week in most weeks to talk
about and the train keeps rolling and
there'll be new story lines
will we yeah we need to think about
effectively all of us will we will
others in the media go back and say
here are the teams that are doing well
here are the teams that are struggling
and these are the teams that had
full-blown off-season programs these are
the teams that curtailed it these are
the teams that didn't have full
attendance will there be a correlation
that's going to be an important exercise
so pete you're the producer
producer crack
future pete
be be aware and keep track and let's see
how that goes because i think it's going
to be an important point it's going to
be interesting to see how it all how it
all fleshes out when it matters it's
going to be important you know just as a
fan of the sport like what we do talking
points anything like that you know all
of that but i mean the teams themselves
are going to be paying attention you
know this they're going to be paying
attention to like you know the analytics
here of like we spent this much time in
the building and had this many practices
and what were the results and they'll go
you know so on and so on with some of
these teams that didn't practice or
whatever so not that there's a huge
huge great advantage that the chiefs are
in the facility in doing that but there
is an advantage there's no doubt you
know they're they're gonna have some
groundwork laid when they get into
training camp to go hey remember we were
doing this at practice a few weeks ago
and blah blah blah we did this at the
end of otas and the mini camps and all
that hey you know as i was in the lab
here i thought about let's add to this
play that we did and did this play
instead of that and that that's where
you get a little bit of an advantage
that way and maybe some of the you know
you get to practice some of the new
curve balls like we're talking about the
coaches might have to for a new attack
the chiefs oh we we didn't have a short
passing attack and that's why we lost
the super bowl maybe we should start
working on it now and i i think that's
where you get the advantages of the
off-season stuff it's not huge but
there's definitely an advantage
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports